this is a pretty typical circle geometry
question and one of the things that make
circle geometry questions difficult is
the sheer amount of information that
they throw at you both verbally and also
visually I mean when you look at this
diagram it's pretty busy there's a lot
going on so rather than focus on all of
these details and kind of get lost in
the trees I'm just going to look at the
question itself and what details in the
question are immediately relevant to
that so they asked us to focus first on
angle C de that's this guy over here and
they say that's X degrees if you know
that show that II OD which interestingly
they have not already included in the
diagram here it is angle yo D is this
guy over here show that it equals to X
degrees okay so this is what I'm
required to prove now the X degree is
the 2x degree is that makes me
suspicious because the property that
relates angles to each other such that
one is double the other is that the
angle Center is double the angle at the
circumference standing on the same arc
now this is a really good sign for me
because the angle I'm interested in
angle äôd it is an angle at the center
so that that's a good thing that's a tic
but the problem is my angle at the
circumference a DC or CDE rather it's
not standing on the same arc these guys
are staying on different arcs so angle a
OD and that's standing on an arc de over
here whereas the original angle angle
CDE it's standing on this arc now this
is the moment where I notice oh the
question said something which is useful
to this is the midpoint of the arc CD
and that's why you can see these
equality lines over here so they may
stand on different arcs but those arcs
are the same in length so I'm going to
take advantage of that fact in a second
here's how I'm going to use that
property
the one about the angles at the center
you can see that arc seee it gives you
the angle CDE here is the arc and it
produces this angle over here C D E and
you can see it standing on the arc it's
like there's two legs but the diagram is
upside
and so the angle that's standing on that
same arc arc CA but is at the center is
going to look like this this is the arc
I'm interested in yeah so CoA this guy
in here I can actually say using the
circle properties that that is 2x
degrees and I'll use the reason that
I've just been stating I can say that
unlike this guy over here which I
actually don't know about the OD that's
one kind of proof so I'm going to delete
that now unlike that guy angles co e is
in fact standing on the same mark as CDE
so I'm going to say that Co E is double
its 2x because it is double angle c da
so my my reasoning I don't have the
space to write it here but my reason he
would look something like this that
angle C a is double the angle C D E and
the reason is that angles are at the
center or angle at the center it doesn't
really matter I've just got one here
angle at the center is double the angle
at the circumference standing on the
same arc that's kind of important at the
circumference standing on the same arc
and that's why we had to go and have a
look at this different angle not the one
we wanted but is related to the one that
we wanted so I'll leave this working
here for a second what I'm gonna need to
get rid of it shortly to replace it with
other working so what have I done so far
I have established that this is 2 X
that's not really the angle that I
wanted I wanted to show that this guy is
2 X so what am I going to use to show
you that well as we mentioned before the
two arcs that we're interested in c e
and de they are both equal I highlighted
these equality signs here so what I'm
going to say now I'm gonna use this
space so let's just make this a little
bit small chocolate over here here we go
so now I can say well the angle that I
really want angle a OD that's the way
they've named it in the question I can
say that it's equal to angle C oh that's
the one I was just working with over
here I can say they are equal because
equal arcs and those arcs are C and D
those guys are equal they some tend
equal angles at the center they certain
echo angles at the centre it's much more
frequent that we say they september
angles at the circumference but these
two theorems these two properties
oh I said circumference so I was
thinking about that I really meant
Center
these two properties are equivalent in
this context so they give me this the
result that I'm after so hooray I've got
2x degrees as well and that's part one
so tick it's finished then in part two
they want us to have a look at this
shape down here oh p RQ they want us to
prove that that is a cyclic
quadrilateral okay now where is Opie RQ
well I can see it in here kind of
nestled in the middle of the diagram and
I just want to point out you can really
see it here right now hopefully I've
demonstrated it that having a large
diagram and also if you want using
colors it's so immensely helpful to be
able to see what's going on and work out
how the shapes within the diagram relate
to each other so there's my shape Opie
RQ and to prove that it is indeed cyclic
what I need to do is think in two
directions number one if it's cyclic
quadrilateral that's what I want to
prove what I want to have in my mind is
what do I know about cyclic
quadrilateral what properties does a
cyclic quadrilateral have because if I
want to prove that it's cyclic I need to
show you that oh PRQ exhibits some of
the properties that a cyclic
quadrilateral is supposed to have so
that's the first direction my mind is
going the second direction is to look at
the question and notice you know for
things like this for example EP is
perpendicular to the diameter a B well
that's a very nice piece of information
and I didn't use it at all for part one
that's not a guarantee but that does
make me strongly suspicious that I could
use it for Part C being that I haven't
used it already and what makes me doubly
suspicious is that that ap being
perpendicular to a B it's what gives me
this right angle here now that right
angle that's related to the
PRQ the quadrilateral I'm interested in
you can see that it is the exterior
angle of that quadrilateral and this
trig is my memory I know something about
the exterior angles of a cyclic
quadrilateral I should be able to say
that the exterior angle of a cyclic
quadrilateral this guy here I should be
able to say that this is equal to the
opposite interior angle now where is
that well you can see it's up here it's
o Q R so if this is indeed cyclic then
that really should be a right angle yeah
it does it look right angled well yes
but of course the diagram is not enough
to judge on is there information in the
question that would lead me to think
that it is right angled and that's a
better question to ask the answer is yes
if we get rid of that because I don't
actually know that that's true yet if
you think about the triangle in which
that angle lives
this guy here I'm always looking for
triangles because in-between similarity
and congruence I know a lot about
triangles and can prove lots of things
okay this angle lives in triangle o D Q
let me highlight it for you so it's sort
of this guy here o DQ you can see it
over there and this triangle is kind of
important to me and useful because it's
related to angle or rather triangle c oq
you see this guy over here
so these two triangles look mighty alike
and there's a good reason for it
if you look at the pieces that make
those up right number one you got two
radii here here and here so they're
radii so they're equal you've also got I
should put two lines on there because
we've already used one line for those
arcs that we sent before you also got
this guy in the middle one two three OQ
either is common to both of those
triangles so I've got two sides that are
equal and the last ingredient is
something that I proved in the previous
part that you've got a 2x here and
you've got a 2x here and it's brilliant
so I've got the included angle that's
going to give me a triangle congruence
so I can say that triangle coq10 two
triangle D Oh cute the reason will be
side angles
and your sides are going to be see and
do
that's the radii you've also got that
included angle so what did we say that
was called you've got see a cube being
equal to d oq which we proved we proved
earlier side say proven above and then
our last piece our other side will be
the common site so I'll say o is common
so BAM I've nailed it these guys are
congruent if they're congruent then all
the other features of the of the
triangles the sides and the angles will
also be equal so I can say hey you know
this this o QR that I'm interested in
its corresponding to CQ o over here so
if angle CQ o is equal to angle OQ ah
but both of these together make a
straight angle 180 degrees you can
probably do the rest of the reason is to
show that it is indeed the 90 degrees we
were after us so I can pop my 90 degrees
in there after having proven it and I
can complete my proof by saying well the
angle here is equal to the exterior
angle so the exterior angle is equal to
the opposite interior angle that's a
property that cyclic quadrilateral rules
exhibit and so tada